bientôt 23h nous nous trouvons devant la
boîte de nuit le pym's à tour et c'est
enfin le grand jour ou plutôt le grand
soir soir de réouverture des
discothèques en france pour rentrer ce
soir le pass vaccinale est exigé les
pièces d'identité sont tout vérifier et
à l'intérieur le masque est recommandée
mais pas obligatoire cette soirée de
retour devrait attirer du monde puisque
plus de 500 personnes avaient déjà pré
réserver leur rentrée ce mercredi après
midi alors êtes vous heureux de revenir
on va aller à votre rencontre qu'est ce
qui vous plaît dans cette ambiance si tu
retrouves l'ambiante logique on sort
c'est une bonne heure et pat on est on
est là c'est reparti toutes les semaines
on est toujours précaire ou de
l'attention que tout le temps enfermé le
côté cool rentrer à la maison plus
pouvoir sortir là ça fait plaisir en
voit des gens des inconnus et du
poubelle c'est cool de pouvoir rpt
sociabiliser on va dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a envie de s'amuser ce soir on a
envie de faire la fête toutes les heures
on va compter comme au nouvel an 19,8 et
voilà on va faire la fête qu'on va
s'amuser on est de quelle humeur ce soir
bas plutôt festive
c'est quoi l'objectif ce soir cette
trouée quelqu'un qui rentre et cette
danse et c'est pour un coût c'est quoi
on s'éclate à pousser
on verra où ça nous a
fait penser à rien et surtout pas commis
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
soit au film tout le monde semble
conquis la soirée ce qu'on espère
surtout c'est de ne pas avoir à fermer à
nouveau le gouvernement de son côté
conte super et le mas vaccinale début du
printemps
[Musique]